The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
Matt was putting a question
on the table for us.
So why don't you go
and lay that out.
And we'll get to the next--
AUDIENCE: This idea of how
you distribute your talents
across R&D sectors.
The economic model
that stands now
is treat technology as
[INAUDIBLE] a box and say this.
Put this much capital
into technology,
and you'll get this
kind of growth,
where it doesn't consider
how you distribute
your capital within that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I'll just give you
an example because you're right
in identifying the problem.
About seven or eight
years ago, there
were a whole series of
major studies of climate
and how are we going to
develop the necessary energy
and related technologies
that were going to be
needed to tackle the problem.
And interestingly, all of those
studies got to this moment
where they were going to
talk about the technologies.
And they all basically
read the same way.
They all said, yes, we're going
to need a lot of technologies.
And then we'll spend a
lot of money on them.
We'll spend a lot of money
doing research and development,
was their conclusion.
And then we need to
spend this much money
on research and development.
Then we need to spend this much.
But we'll spend a lot of money
on research and development.
There was never an attempt
to get inside that black box,
as you well put it, Matt,
of how that innovation
system is actually organized
to optimize the results.
That is our problem.
That is the problem
of this class,
getting inside that black
box and figuring out
how these innovation
systems actually work
and how you can optimize
the organization of them.
And we're going to look
at a bunch of models
and a bunch of problems,
exactly along those lines.
But if we do
nothing else, you're
going to get deep inside
that black box and, I think,
start to understand some
of the elements you've
got to think about when you
design your way out of it.
Does that help?
Because you're right.
It's been a classic problem
in science and tech policy
that it hasn't really faced
the innovation organization
problems.
It hasn't understood
how important they are.
But I think they're really key.
And we really jump into
that in the next class.
All right.
So we're now at our third
great growth economist,
Dale Jorgenson, who teaches
up the street at Harvard.
And Jorgenson I put
in here basically
because he improves the model.
He takes a look at the
1990s IT boom, that period
of rapid growth,
and shows that that
is driven by technological
and related innovation.
And the resurgence
in the US economy
in that '93 to 2001 period
really outran all expectations.
And his view is that
there is the rapid decline
in IT prices for a technology
that inherently increases
productivity in important
ways and costs ever less.
That's a huge driver
and was key to the surge
in the 1990s growth.
And he argues that the core
technology in the IT wave
was semiconductors.
So let me just
walk through this.
You all probably
know a fair amount
of the semiconductor history.
Bell Labs in 1947 with Bardeen,
Brattain, and Shockley,
they developed the transistor
from semiconductor materials.
And it's an electrical
switching device.
It enables essentially the whole
follow on of digital technology
innovation.
It's that digital
form that's key.
And then following on that
comes the integrated circuit.
And that really evolves in 1958.
And it's developed in
two different sites, two
different great groups frankly.
Jack Kilby was the leader of
a team at Texas Instruments.
Robert Noyce is the
leader of a team
at Fairchild Semiconductor.
And Fairchild later
morphs into Intel.
And they develop the
integrated circuit.
Gordon Moore, who's working
with Noyce at Fairchild
Semiconductor, watching
what's going on,
he develops Moore's law, which
is a good way of describing
what Jorgenson is onto.
The integrated circuit,
every two years,
is going to double the number
of transistors per chip.
And the cost per transistor
is going to decline by half
in that same two years-- and
sometimes, it's 18 months--
kind of time period.
So in other words, you have
much greater capability
at ever lower cost.
That's the phenomena that's
at the core of this innovation
wave.
And that is often
what's happening.
You'll have a core technology
with a declining cost base
that gets evermore
capable at a lower cost.
So you introduce, in effect,
a deflationary factor
into your technology
advanced process.
So in '68, Noyce, Moore,
and Andy Grove found Intel.
And they move over to
microprocessors or logic chips,
microchips, which is a bundle
of transistors playing out
this Moore's law theory.
So Jorgenson looks
at semiconductors
as the core technology advance.
And under Moore's law, it's
coming down by half every two
years in cost.
Communications equipment cost
is also coming down driven by,
in large part, cheaper
semiconductors.
So all kinds of
transmission technologies
are occurring at
this time period.
I've listed some of them there
that are coming down in price.
And the result is
a technology that's
creating major new productivity
gains in the economy.
In other words,
you're producing more
for less with less labor input.
Therefore, you're
creating a real gain,
which amounts to a new real
wealth in the society, which
you can distribute.
That's the pattern here.
And the result is a
growth resurgence.
So there's price declines in
computing and communications
equipment, computing equipment.
Between '90 and 1995, Jorgenson
traces a 15%-a-year price
decline, between '95 and
2000, a 32% decline per year.
In other words, this
thing is costing evermore
capable and costing a lot
less in relatively short time
periods.
Now, the outlier
here is software.
And this is how
Bill Gates gets rich
because the decline in price
in software is only 1.6%
between '90 and '95 and only
2.4% between '95 and 2000.
So in other words, you
can still charge a premium
for your software even if
the hard technology cost
is coming down significantly.
So that's why Gates and
Microsoft get bigger than IBM
because IBM bet on
the wrong category.
And we still haven't tackled
this cost of software problem.
It's still too much of
an art form frankly.
But there's big growth
in the '90s in this area,
much higher than any other
kind of capital good.
And it becomes pervasive
in the economy.
It's in homes.
And it's in every business.
And it's in government.
And the productivity numbers.
From 1945 to 1973, the
productivity growth rate
in the US is in the 2% range.
And then from '73 to
'93, productivity rate
falls much lower
into the 1% range.
And then from '95 to 2000,
productivity rate is 3.5%.
And economic growth,
in turn, is 4.2%.
These are astonishing numbers.
Historical US growth rate is 3%.
In that '73 to '93 period,
it falls down to 2%.
Productivity falls
down to the 1% range.
That's a grim period.
That is a grim period in the US.
And getting out of
that grim period really
felt pretty amazing.
Guess what?
Our current growth rate
is in the 2% range.
And our current productivity
rate is in the 1% range.
It doesn't feel
robust and dynamic.
A lot of people are
getting left behind.
What we need?
New innovation-based
growth wave.
That's what Jorgenson
is writing about.
That's what turned these
numbers around in the 1990s.
And again, I want
you to understand
the relationship between
growth and productivity gains.
Again, productivity
gains are what
create that real gain in
society that you can distribute.
And they get driven by
technological advance.
Productivity gains get
driven predominantly
by technological advance.
So that's Jorgenson's picture.
He essentially proves the model.
He basically shows, by looking
at a period of a big innovation
wave, that Solow
has got it right.
It's technological-based
innovation
that's driving that amazing
period of economic growth
in the 1990s.
So questions about this.
AUDIENCE: For that dip
in the '70s to '90s,
is that mostly attributed to
policy or demographic change?
What was going on there that was
resulting in lower innovation?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There's
a number of things going on.
It's not so much demographics
change in that period of time.
Now, we've got much more
significant demographics
issues.
And the cost of an aging
demographic because you're
going to have to pay for me.
And I'm going to take a
lot of your real wealth.
It's an intergenerational
transfer now.
We didn't really have
much of that going on
in that time period.
It was the ascendancy of a
baby boom, which in some ways
is the opposite.
But in that period, that's
when the competition with Japan
hits.
And we'll talk more about this.
But in the post
World War II period,
the US organizes its
innovation system.
And it organizes its
innovation system
around leading these
innovation waves.
And it ends up leading
almost all of them in that
late-20th-century,
second-half-of-the-20th-century
period.
And it gets very
rich because it's
getting the first mover
advantage of these innovation
waves.
So we create the
richest nation on Earth.
And then it misses one.
And we'll talk more
about this in class 3.
But Japan figures out
quality manufacturing.
It's an innovation wave.
It's a whole new way
of doing production.
And out of that, Japan is able
to capture very large parts
of consumer electronics
and the auto sector,
which had been core
sectors in the US economy.
So a fair amount of what's
going on between '73 and '93
is that the US misses
an innovation wave.
Now, interestingly,
then what happens?
Then we have this boom time.
What did we do?
We brought on another
innovation wave.
This is the IT wave.
That's what Jorgenson
is telling us.
And fascinatingly,
Japan missed it.
So there's a lot of
lessons here that we'll
talk about when we get to
the manufacturing class.
But go ahead, Max.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
mean, if you've got companies
like Sony that did very well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I'll describe for you,
Matt-- let me interrupt
since you mentioned Sony.
So I'm in Japan
in January of 2006
speaking at a big conference
organized by the US National
Academies and similar
organizations in Japan.
And the meeting is on
innovation systems actually.
And the headline in the
major Japanese newspaper--
and there's a major Japanese
English language newspaper.
The headline is-- bold
headline across the front--
Apple Sells 14 Million iPods,
semicolon, where is Sony,
question mark, question mark.
Apple took back a large part of
that consumer innovation wave.
Snatched it because of defeat
at the hands of great companies
like Sony.
So the US was--
US quote because Apple
doesn't make anything here--
was able to take
back leadership of
an important because of its
leadership of a computing
revolution.
In effect, it adds a
computing revolution
onto what that had been
consumer electronics
and then leads in
that territory.
And that's what's
playing out in this time
period of the innovation wave.
But we'll dive into this when we
get to the manufacturing class.
So anything else on Jorgenson?
What do you think?
Is he right?
Is this the right picture?
I think the economic
evidence is pretty
overwhelming on this one.
It looks really pretty
clear what happened.
And to this model of a core
invention, apps pile on it,
semiconductors, apps pile
around it like the internet.
And then it becomes innovation.
And then it becomes
an innovation wave.
And then it spreads
throughout the economy.
And then it creates
big productivity gains.
And then you can translate
those productivity gains
into a real gain in
your society, which
means a real new
wealth in your society
which you can distribute.
That looks very clear
that that happens.
So a major issue in the class is
how do you how do you do these?
Can we do these?
Can we speed the pace?
I mean, typically, they happen
about every 40 or 50 years.
Could you reduce
the interim period?
One way of looking at
what's going on now
is we're just
waiting for a wave.
It's like we're surfers paddling
around waiting for that wave
to kind of take us.
And I don't know what
that wave is going to be.
But it could be very
interesting because we
seem to do these about
every 40 or 50 years.
But then the question is,
are we going to lead it?
So if the next big wave
worldwide is energy,
and there's certainly a
case that it might be,
are we going to have a
first-mover advantage
in a lot of these technologies
and get some of the gains?
Or not?
I think that's a
pretty open question.
AUDIENCE: Chime in.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Martin, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
in general, that's
the classic thing of, if we
miss the next wave, your economy
will plummet too.
And that's probably
what happened in Japan.
The big concern, though, is
like most like Schwinger,
who's the nuclear scientist
in the 50's, 60's, talked
about how, if we do nuclear, it
wouldn't be possible in the US,
It would probably have
to be somewhere in Asia
because we're just kind
of close-minded to it.
And then if you look
into recent examples,
like Bill Gates funded
a fission company that's
doing a new kind of reactor.
But the policy just so hard
here that they're just doing it
in China because it's faster.
And I think Romer also
talks about charter cities
where you have less rules.
So it's easier to
innovate quickly.
So that's another thing.
There's like this saying where,
if you outlaw innovation,
only outlaws will evolve.
If you make it really
hard to innovate,
people are just going
to go somewhere else.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I think those
are important points, Martin.
And this is a legacy
sector problem.
In other words, the US--
and we'll talk about this a
lot when we get to energy.
And we'll read about it.
But the US is pretty
good at creating
these kind of new
frontier territories,
standing up these new areas.
We're not good at
bringing innovation back
into established sectors.
We'd just rather do
the next big thing.
And that's not bad.
But when a lot of
your social problems
are tied to the legacy
sectors, then it
becomes a big disadvantage.
Now, that's not to say
that countries in general
are good at innovating
in legacy sectors.
They're not.
There's a problem for everybody.
But I think we're
particularly bad at it.
And think of what the big
societal problems are.
Energy efficiency and
moving to a new generation
of energy technologies.
We've got to figure
out how to do that.
But that means learning how to
innovate in a legacy sector.
We've got a terrible problem
with health care delivery,
terrible.
We do the new thing.
We'll do biotech.
We'll create the new frontier.
We just don't go back and fix
the health care delivery system
because it's tough.
We'd rather do biotech.
So a lot of our
societal problems
are tied up in this stuff.
And as we'll talk about
in a couple of weeks,
manufacturing has
played a critical role
in creating a very deep
inequality problem in society,
the failure of that sector.
And again, we're not good
at going back and bringing
innovation, i.e.
the next generation
of advanced manufacturing, into
an established legacy sector.
So this legacy sector
problem actually
turns out to be a big one.
And that'll be one of
the themes of the class.
I'm stealing my own thunder
for a few weeks now.
But you get an advance snapshot.
Chloe?
AUDIENCE: Are we at a new point
in our history of innovation
because we have too many
next big things that we're
having problems following
through creating an innovation
wave?
We have health care and
space and energy and nuclear.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I don't think it's bad to have
a big menu to get waves out of.
I think that's fine.
And the other thing I should say
is not all waves are big waves.
In other words, waves are
of different size here.
Biotech is not a big a
wave as an IT sector.
But it sure is an
important wave.
And you don't want to miss it.
So we're going to have different
waves of different sizes.
So having a lot of candidates
for waves, I think,
is actually a pretty
important thing.
Because it's hard
to predict where
the big innovation
waves will actually go.
Does that answer that?
Any other thoughts?
All right, let's do this
Merrill Lynch piece.
So here's the question that
this-- this is a little Merrill
Lynch report that is
sent just before 9/11,
interestingly, when
the markets went bust.
This was done on
September 4, 2001.
And disaster is only days ahead.
But this is that they're
riding the IT innovation wave.
And they're trying to assess
what innovation waves are
and how their investors
can get rich off of them.
And in a capitalist economy,
that's not an unimportant task.
So how do investors look
at potential technology
breakthroughs?
Do they believe that
they drive growth?
So what does the Merrill
report out to its investors,
tell its investors?
Well, they say, yes.
Innovation drives growth
so you want to get on this.
You really want to get on
these innovation waves.
And then Norman
Piore, who I think
is related to MIT's
Michael Piore, who's
a wonderful professor of
entrepreneurship and technology
advances at Sloan, has
done important work
on a lot of things,
including DARPA
and including manufacturing.
So I think Norman and
Michael are related.
But I haven't asked him.
But Norman Piore, who's
the chief economist
for Merrill Lynch
at the time, he
said, yes, innovation-based
growth drives the economy.
And by the way, it
drives the stock market.
And then he goes on to say--
and where he gets
this, I don't know.
But he says, it takes 28 years
for widespread acceptance
of a new technology.
That's-- is it always 28 years?
Maybe it's 27.
I don't know.
Then it takes 56 years for
rapid growth to evolve.
And then it takes
112 years measured
from here for technological
maturity to occur.
And then after that,
growth in that sector
is going to resemble
growth in population rates.
Well, I don't know
where he gets the 28
years, 56 years, 112 years.
I don't know where
that comes from.
But this is the chief economist
of Merrill Lynch saying,
yes, this is how it works.
This is how it happens.
That's interesting.
It's not just an obscure
economist conjury
of growth wave.
This is advice going
out from, then,
the largest stock, broad-based
investment company in the US.
Then they hit on, what's
the wave we're going to hit?
So they think nano.
That's the one, nanotechnology.
So they describe an
interesting pattern here,
which I think is
actually very important.
It's really, I think,
very perceptive.
I don't know where the 28 year
comes from although the time
frames are roughly right.
But this, I think,
is really intriguing.
And I want you to
think about this.
So they say, let's
look at nanotechnology.
And as you know,
that's fabrication
of the mark of the scale.
And first, for a technology
to evolve and get
into range of being innovation
and maybe an innovation wave,
first, there's got
to be a vision.
Somebody has to present a vision
of what this technology could
accomplish.
And they argued that the first
vision about nanotechnology
was from physicist Richard
Feynman, a famous physicist who
went to school here, of course,
and was in the Manhattan
Project and then unfortunately
taught at an obscure California
school called Caltech.
But Feynman, in a
1959 piece, argued,
in the physics
community, there's
plenty of room at the bottom.
In other words, at the
really small scales
were quantum effects can occur,
some really interesting things
can happen.
And that's the nano scale.
So he gives a
vision that we could
do some really
interesting stuff when
you're operating outside
of Newtonian physics
at a smaller scale.
So the second piece
that has to occur they
refer to as enablers.
So there's got to be, in effect,
tool sets and instruments
that enable this vision
to get played out.
And the key tool set
in that time period
was when IBM did the scanning
tunneling electron microscope.
And you probably
don't remember this.
But there was a moment
when IBM, before there
was much of an internet,
distributed photographs
of stacks of molecules
spelling out the IBM logo
and to civilians like me, I
said, oh, that looks very nice.
But to scientists
seeing an ability
to structure molecules
in that kind of way
was just absolutely amazing.
So the scanning tunneling
electron microscope
is not only an observing system.
It's a device by which you
can move molecules around.
So it becomes a huge
capability in allowing
measurement and manipulation
in nanoscale systems.
So that's when this
article was written.
That was 20 years before.
The third piece that this
Merrill Lynch piece talks
about, which I also think
is really important,
is this is straight
out of Romer.
You've got to create
research mass.
In other words, you got to
put talent on the problem.
This is human capital
engaged in research.
So Eric Drexler, from MIT,
in a 1981 journal article,
begins to describe the kind
of physics and possibilities
in nanotechnology.
That's the first one.
By 2000, there are 1,800
journal articles on nano.
And by the way, that's
a similar phenomena
to the number of
articles starting
to write about the
internet in the 1990s.
In other words, this
journal article total
signals research mass.
It signals prospectors.
It signals human capital
engaged in research.
So these are, I think, really
interesting conceptual points
here.
And you have to go through these
to get to your innovation slash
innovation wave.
You need the vision.
You need the enabling tools.
And then you need talent on
the task, this research mass.
And you've got to go through
all three steps to get there.
That's interesting.
And then they come
to, how are we
going to tell our investors
to get rich off this?
Because we've gone through
the three stages for nano.
We've got 1,800 journal
articles the previous year.
We've got research mass.
How are we going to get rich?
And then they
issue this warning.
Although the futuristic
market is fascinating,
it is not inevitable.
So just because you're
approaching the future,
it doesn't mean you're
always going to get rich.
So how are you
going to get rich?
They acknowledge that
nanotechnology in 2001
is starting to get close
to commercial markets.
And then they
review key markets,
which we would view as
hilariously short term.
So zero to two
years, short term,
zero to five years, mid-term.
Five-plus years is long term.
Now, remember Norman Piore?
It takes 28 years to do this
and takes 56 years to do this.
It takes 112 years to do this.
Those are long periods of time.
These guys are
talking about trying
to get rich in what we
would view as extremely
short-term periods.
And they give you
a good perspective
as to how far out investors
are even willing to look.
And they argued that the
keys to nanotechnology
are manufacturing
and communication.
If you can't build it
in volume, then there's
not much you can do with it.
So they look at a series of
opportunities with that idea
behind.
They look at
opportunity number 1--
instrumentation.
And they note that, as a new
technology is advancing along,
the first class of winners
are the tool makers.
So we'll go back to our
California Gold Rush in 1849.
The first people to get
really rich in California
are those that are supplying
those miners that are
headed off to the gold fields.
The tool makers tend
to be an early class.
So for heaven's sakes, let's
invest in the tool makers
because they're critical
to everybody else.
Everybody is going
to need their stuff.
Let's invest in that stuff.
Then they look at
semiconductors.
And they note that,
within 10 years, if you're
going to stay on
Moore's law, you're
going to have to get
deep into nanotechnology,
which, of course, turns
out to be the case.
But that could take 10 years.
So forget that.
They're not going to
advise any investors
to get into that business.
Instead, they
really want to focus
on stuff that can evolve
in two years or less.
So if Norman is right and
technology development takes
a really long time
measured in decades
and Merrill is only willing
to invest for what it refers
to as the short-term
zero to two years,
there is a big
disconnect in our ability
to stand up technologies.
We're just not operating
at a plausible frame.
And who is going to
fund the rest of it?
I don't think Norman's 28
years is necessarily right.
But it's a long time.
And who is going to fund that?
Who's going to carry this
stuff for that extended period
if Merrill and the boys
are only willing to do
a two-year timetable?
This is a big gap in
the innovation system.
And when we were talking a few
minutes ago about the problems
we've got in standing
up hard technologies,
investment at scale, if
it's only going to focus
on a two-year time
frame-- in other words,
you've got to get to production
in the short term to really
have this investable, to
work as an investment,
so you're not going to want to
invest in technologies that are
more than two years
out from production--
then you're taking an enormous
amount of interesting things
off the table here.
So it's a really big
structural problem.
The answer that the US has
come up with historically
is that the federal government
will play a long-term role.
The federal government will
provide the long-term patient
capital.
But that's not a perfect
model either because of what
we'll talk about next week,
this valley of death problem.
So you following me?
So this is a classic kind of
innovation system problem.
So when you're thinking
about innovation systems,
you're going to have to
think about the actors
in that system, the
handoffs between the actors,
and then the time
frames that the actor is
going to need support.
So this is another
way of helping
us think about how to look
at innovation systems.
Any questions flow from this?
Because this is a
big challenge here.
The venture capital time
frame is basically organized
for everything
except biotech when
looking at technologies that are
no more than a couple of years
out from production.
So the US created this amazing
venture capital system,
which, in many ways, is
the envy of the world.
And it works very nicely for IT.
And it works for very
different reasons
that we'll talk
about for biotech.
But it's not working in
these hard technology sectors
because the timetables
are just too long
and the risks are too
high and the uncertainties
are too great.
So this is a big gap in
the innovation system.
Merrill Lynch doesn't look at
it as a gap in the innovation
system.
But that's really what
they're showing us exists.
And then the other
important thing
to remember about what
they present us with
is I think this very perceptive
notion that you need to go
through these three stages.
You need to move a technology
from invention and discovery
to innovation--
vision, the enabling
technologies, and then
the research mass, the human
capital engaged in research,
the talent base.
AUDIENCE: So are
innovation systems,
like Bell Labs,
just unsustainable?
Or why haven't we seen
anything like that?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I mean, we'll
deal with this a bit next week.
And you should, Beth, bring
me back to this next week
for sure.
The short story--
and we'll spend
a little more time on this.
Bell Labs was tied
and was able to have
very patient long-term
supportive technology
because it was tied to a
government-guaranteed monopoly
model.
And when we broke up AT&T
and the segments that
survived were placed in a highly
competitive situation with one
another plus an IT revolution,
which created an entirely
different communication
system around the internet,
was descending, then
Bell Labs' ability
to sustain a model
of long-term patient
investment in breakthrough
technology advance, it's gone.
And by and large,
with some exceptions,
the model of the large
industry-supported, basic and
applied research laboratory
has largely gone.
There's still some pieces left.
IBM, although that's under
a lot of economic pressure
as it tries to shift to
a service-based business
and wonders why it's doing
hard technology research.
That's a remaining piece.
But it's not what it was
a decade ago in terms
of its basic research support.
So there's few of these left.
And the model of incredible
global competition
has really eroded the
ability of a company
to take a long-term risk over
highly hypothetical research
advances that are
very high risk.
It's just really eroded this.
So what's been happening?
So universities are
increasingly being
asked to take this job on.
So universities have gone from a
19th-century model of education
as their dominant driver
to a mid-20th-century model
of adding research to
education and merging those to,
in recent decades, playing an
economic role, which they never
played before, and
trying to figure out
how to play that role.
Because, in effect,
they're the surrogate piece
to substitute for
the Bell Labs model
to sustaining longer-term,
higher-risk technology
development.
And they're just beginning
to figure out how to do this.
So the engine at MIT is a
really interesting model,
which we'll talk about.
And if anybody has any
ties over the engine,
we probably ought to go
over there and take a look
at what they're up to,
wander down the street,
and talk to them.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Go ahead, Max.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What is the engine?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
We'll talk about it.
But MIT is attempting to
create a place for startups
that are right up against this
wall of not getting venture
support doing primarily hard
technologies where they can
live and have access to
advanced equipment, advanced
technologies, and
a lot of know-how.
So in effect, it's substituting
a place for the kind of stuff
that they had to carry out
with venture funding before.
So if you throw a
group of them together,
they have shared assets--
in effect, Creative Commons--
rely on this campus but also
secondary nodes like Lincoln
Labs, like some
companies that are
interested in this model
to help them scale up
their technologies.
So there's a lot of incubators
in this neighborhood.
We have eight incubators
very close to MIT.
And they're very interesting.
And some of them are terrific.
The incubator tends to focus
on getting your business
plan together and
kind of perfecting
your initial prototype.
This is an attempt
to do something
that goes to much
later stages to help
you do the advanced prototype,
late-stage development,
demonstration, test
bed, and maybe even
pilot production,
which is typically what
you get venture funding for.
But the timetables don't
work for venture funding.
Maybe by substituting
space for venture capital,
you could create a
different kind of model.
So MIT is busy taking
this amazing adventure
trying to do this.
And that's just
a classic example
of how university
is going to have
to wrestle with their
new economic role
to get around this Merrill
Lynch-identified problem
for us.
AUDIENCE: Also, there's
sufficient capital--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
Right.
And part of this--
pure space doesn't
always solve the problem.
You're going to need
some bridge funding.
So part of this is
raising some money.
And could you raise--
the return on venture capital
is designed to be high.
And it is designed to
be pretty short term
to get your money back in
a pretty reasonable time
period in these venture funds.
This is not going to happen
with these hard technologies,
a number of which will be coming
out of Martha's world of energy
technology development.
Is there a community
out there that's
prepared to tolerate a
much lower-level-return,
higher-risk, and long-term focus
just for societal well-being.
Stefania?
AUDIENCE: Estefania.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Estefania.
AUDIENCE: There you go.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
You're going to get
me to do this right.
I promise.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
precisely why it's
so interesting to study the
nonprofit development model
and why it's important
to understand
how to rebrand science and
technology innovation processes
and systems in particular
because nonprofits,
for a very long
time, and especially
community-led and
local nonprofits,
have understood exactly the
consequences of resource
scarcity no matter how
good their ideas are.
And that's why precisely
I appreciate it
on her articulation
of the ways in which--
was it the Manhattan Project in
Kansas, the great teams model?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Great groups, yes.
AUDIENCE: This model that
we'll talk about later.
But I do think it's
important to have
a sort of critical literacy of
funding models in the way that
does impact the kind of
research that you can pursue
and also how that
funding model will impact
the ways in which
you'll have to construct
your narrative of
success, whether that's
through a publication
or the product
that you actually
end up producing.
Because it turns
out that there's
different kinds
of venture models.
And I'm sure that MIT is very
cognizant of the ways in which
donor-specified funding plays
a role in shaping what you can
and cannot pursue
as a researcher.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
And interestingly,
exactly as you say,
we're starting to play around
with different mechanisms
including a number of
nonprofit mechanisms, that
would help us to kind of fill
this gap in the innovation
system.
And in effect, Martin,
back to your point,
enable us to have a
lot more kitchens.
All right.
Let me see if I can draw
some conclusions here.
This class has talked
about two direct innovation
factors, things
that I would argue
that you can't do without.
So if Solow, which
its growth is driven
by technological and related
innovation, is right--
it's responsible for 2/3 of
historic US economic growth--
then having an R&D system
is a pretty critical pillar.
And you need to
invest in that system.
So that's factor number 1.
Let's look at some
of the numbers.
And this is-- one of the
readings this week was
from NSF indicators.
And NSF indicators comes
out every other year.
It is the great collection
of data on the US innovation
system with lots of comparative
international assessments
as well.
And it's just a great
tool set for you
as you look at
innovation systems
and need to make
comparative analysis.
So don't miss it.
I don't want you to read it.
Just glance at it.
See the kinds of
things that they
that they can collect
data for you on
and what those plots look like.
And I'm pulling a few
of my favorite charts,
sometimes innovators but almost
always from NSF-developed data.
Federal research funding.
So this is federal R&D
outlays as a percentage
of total federal government
discretionary spending
between '62 and 2008.
And you see that
discretionary spending on R&D
began to approach
it's like 17% in 1965.
And then it comes down
to well below 10%,
and actually barely
above 8% by 2010.
So that's another way of
looking at that same curve.
So that blue curve is a
slightly different measurement.
But that's essentially
the decline
of federal government support.
But then you see, in the purple,
it's an interesting x curve.
So you see an increase in
industry support for R&D
over that same time period.
By the way, you can
extrapolate this out
and the same phenomenon occurs.
And this x curve is
a very famous curve.
So you think, oh, well,
it's too bad that government
is pulling out of
R&D. But isn't it nice
that industry is taking over.
And great.
Problem solved.
Because we're essentially at
the same percentage of GDP
that goes to R&D as we
were back in the 1960s.
So no problem.
But then you figure out that
these two different lines
are measuring-- it's
apples and oranges.
Government supports
predominantly research.
Industry supports
predominantly development.
Is there a relationship between
research and development?
Well, yes, of course, there is
a relationship between research
and development.
To a significant
extent, research
is going to drive development
over an extended period
of time.
So then this picture
becomes very problematic.
In a way, the government
investment back here
enabled this big
industry build-up
in development that
followed afterwards
over decades afterwards.
But if you're bringing down
your research, over time,
that's going to affect your
ability to do development.
So this x curve, it's a
very problematic curve
for the future of US innovation
because what you want
are two parallel rising lines.
You want rising research,
which in turn is going
to enable rising development.
You don't want either or.
It doesn't work.
I mean, there's
a phenomena here.
You have to understand why was
this government level so high.
Imagine that.
2/3 of R&D is being spent
by the federal government
here in the 1960s.
What's going on?
Space race.
Cold War.
And hot war.
So we've got simultaneously
a hot war, Cold War,
and space race.
That does wonders for
science investment.
And obviously, fortunately,
we haven't replicated that,
to the extent anyway,
that it occurred back
in that time period.
That's the x curve.
Let me go back to this.
This is investment
in development,
which, as you can look, you
can see the x curve there.
And that's investment
in basic research.
So government dominates
basic research.
The blue industry
dominates development.
Why percentage of GDP?
Is that real?
That's the best
measure for showing
what the societal
commitment is to research.
How much of your society's
wealth are you spending on R&D?
That's probably the
best measure that
shows the societal commitment.
This is where it goes.
So health is the blue.
And that's been
the big expanding
area in federal R&D funding.
And that doubles
starting in 1988.
And you can see that take
off, whereas the rest
is fairly stagnant.
Here's another way
of looking at that.
Federal non-defense research and
development trends as a share
of GDP--
health now dominates.
Other nations are
obviously working hard
on building their
R&D capability.
And you can see that red line
of the US kind of stagnating.
A lot of other countries
aren't following
that model, particularly
China on the bottom.
They understand the
need for R&D investment.
So these are some ways of
looking at that Solow thing.
What are we doing on R&D?
These are ways of quantifying
the investment levels
around R&D, both on the
governmental side, which
tends to dominate research,
and the industry side, which
tends to dominate development.
And the pictures are not ones
that we really want to have.
Let's look at our second direct
innovation factor, the Romer
factor, the talent factor.
So if Romer is right, human
capital engagement research
is the critical
input for the follow
on technological innovation.
It's a prerequisite for
running your R&D system.
And that's the prospector theory
and the talent-based theory
of growth.
So then talent
development becomes
another key pillar for
looking at the strength
of your innovation economy
and looking at your innovation
capable.
So let's look at some of this.
That's natural science
and engineering doctorates
in selected countries.
And you see particularly
this incredible rise
in degrees coming out of
China but a lot of growth
in a number of other
countries as well
and a fair amount of
stagnation in the US.
This US innovation
depends on the presence
of foreign-born
scientists and engineers.
That's a very important
part of our system.
And that's how this
curve has taken off.
So this is very important input
into the US innovation system.
That's why immigration is such
a huge concern for the 400 tech
companies that filed the amicus
brief for today's argument.
This is the annual
growth rate on numbers
of researchers by country.
I mean, the US has the
largest research pool by far.
But the growth
rate is much lower.
You see the rising growth rates
in a series of Asian economies.
This is world share of natural
science and engineering
publications.
You actually see a decline
in world share from the US
and, obviously, a huge rise
in world share from China,
but also countries
like South Korea.
Significant increases in
first university degrees
in natural science
and engineering
in China against the
rest of the world.
China, rest of the world, right?
They get an innovation-based
growth model.
That's what they're after.
They understand its importance.
They are a developing
economy that's
become an emerging
using an innovation-based
growth model for its growth.
So these are ways of looking
at talent and the strength
of your innovation system.
And the NSF
indicators can tell us
a lot about the second
pillar, this Paul Romer
pillar, this talent pillar.
Now, where did these
direct innovation
system factors come
from, these two?
Well, on the direct
governmental role,
federal government funding
of university research
is obviously key.
And government dominates
research investment as we saw.
Things like government labs are
obviously government dominated.
The education and
training system, these
are Romer-type factors.
The federal government dominates
higher education support
for science and engineering.
Support for industry
R&D, that's pretty
significant on the
government side,
particularly through
the Defense Department.
And sometimes some
other agency missions,
but DoD is the big one.
So this is the
government playing
a role in direct innovation
factors, both education and R&D
investment.
But then the private sector
plays a significant role
in these two direct
innovation factors as well.
So industry R&D, which
as we talked about,
it's primarily development.
Industry takes things through
the engineering prototyping
and production stages.
The training system is
dominated by industry.
So that's a Romer-like factor.
So you see the division
between public sector
and private sector roles around
these two innovation system
pillar.
Any questions about
this data stuff?
So let's do some wrap-up.
Robert Solow, the key
to economic growth
is technology and
related innovation.
And for shorthand-- although
it's not a fair summary,
but in shorthand, we could say
that you've got to do R&D. Then
we talked about Paul Romer.
Behind that technological
and related innovation
factor is what he calls human
capital engaged in research.
It's your talent base.
But again, it's got
to be in the system.
It can't be driving cabs.
It's gotta be in that system.
And Dale Jorgenson tells us
that the key to 1990s growth
actually was technological
and related innovation,
that Solow is absolute right.
That's how the economy grew.
And we saw the picture
that he presented
for us of a core
technology, semiconductors,
applications pile around
it, it enters the economy
at significant scale and
starts to affect many sectors.
That enables productivity gains.
The productivity
gains is a real gain
in the society, which
can be distributed
to improve societal well-being.
That's the picture he uses
to show how these innovation
waves actually operate.
And then from the Merrill
Lynch piece that we read,
we learn that investors
are only prepared to tackle
a pretty small slice of
that long-term technology
development time
frame that's needed.
They acknowledge
that it's long term.
They're going to focus on
a very short part of it.
So you've got automatically a
big gap in the US innovation
system that's going to
have to get wrestled with.
And then the last
piece we went through
were these direct innovation
factors, R&D and talent,
and the different roles that
both government and private
sector play in these two.
And we looked at
the NSF indicators
as a good source for
you for terrific data
on how to look at innovation,
the US innovation systems
but also comparative analysis
with other nations as well.